our buddy Pete from Ocean View Delaware
who said he wanted to come and hang out
at the show um he is in fact here and
we're gonna get more from Pete later on
in our number three cuz we all here know
what it's like to beat cancer and
battled cancer is this man is doing
right now and as our next guest here on
the Rich Eisen show certainly knows all
about and that is Jim Kelly Pro Football
Hall of Famer whose football life
premieres on NFL Network Friday at 9:00
Eastern Time on the NFL Network and
whose 5 and 2 bills go against the Jets
tonight how are you Jim I'm doing pretty
good how about yourself I'm better for
chatting with you always you know that
Jim you know that how you feeling I
always love to start my conversation
that way with you I'm pretty good you
know what the bottom line to find out
that you know there are so many other
people to have a worse and they don't
need to hear my complaints and it's
interesting you bring that up because
when we're at the Hall of Fame people go
how you feel you know and I go this is
one place you never complained about
anything because I'm a young punk in the
Hall of Fame so there's all the guys
yeah there's still a bunch of young guys
but so many older guys that are going
through all the tough times so they
never need my problems so I'm doing
pretty good rich I'm a blessed man no
good to hear that and I want to get to
your football life in a second to me Jim
you know there's been two five and two
teams for the bills since that Music
City miracle day okay this one no this
one feels different to me this one feels
like this is a real 5 and 2 where a team
has an opportunity for a magical run to
win this division in playoffs I'm
wondering what it looks like from your
perspective Jim I totally agree hundred
percent
it'd be a little different if I didn't
feel the vibes coming from over there
and if I've been here to head coach Sean
McDermott the way he talks the people
that I know the guys that I've known for
a long time over there how their
attitudes are different and you know
what they're believing in each other and
I don't think they've had that feeling
in that locker room for a long time and
we as fans and I can say I'm you know
even a former player anytime anything
positive happened in seed okay what's
going to happen now what's gonna fall
out or a big play out first thing you do
you look back okay you know there's
gonna be a penalty in the past there was
and we've gotten past that I think toast
McDermott has these guys believe in each
other and I think more importantly to
discipline I think is finally back I
think people are starting to lean on
each other be self discipline people and
no longer you know getting away with
things that you know you might have
gotten away with in the past I think
they all are coming together as a group
but the big key for us right now I think
just staying healthy and and find ways
to win these games and we have were five
and two and I'm excited I know the city
is well let's stay a little bit on
McDermott here for a second Jim when you
say you hear how he's talking give me an
example what what how is he talking what
is he saying that leads you to believe
is somebody who knows what championship
coaching and championship quality sounds
like to lead you to believe that well he
yeah he talks about the locker room he
talks about how people are really
holding each other accountable they're
doing the things that maybe in the past
they wouldn't have done in rich you know
that when you have that feeling in the
locker when whether it's good or bad you
you thrive on it you go with him and
sometimes when it you haven't had things
go your way
you know you're just waiting for
something to fall out but right now just
listen to him talk about how the players
are believing in each other the guys
that needed to step up the younger guys
and haven't had that chance and he was
talking I think was yesterday or the day
before about some of these guys you know
well he's about know you're not a backup
you're playing now you're a starter
think that way don't think that I'm just
in here for time being so so so gets
healthy or maybe this is mark to know
you are a starter you're not a backup
you're not number two you're the starter
now so just some of the way he goes
about it and even talking to Terry
kimple guru on the sidelines last week
the look on their faces smiles they
finally are getting a team that they
believe in and you know I think those
he's starting to feel that way well I'm
no longer yeah you as a quarterback I
always used to win a big play happens
you always look to see where that
penalty flag is but I don't think people
are really looking towards that as much
anymore as they did in the past that
okay it's gonna be called back and
everyone's wrong you know it happens
it's football but I think they're
starting to get the disciplinary
reactions from each other and knowing
that what we're doing we're doing
together we can't afford to screw up and
Jim Kelly Pro Football Hall of Famer
joining me here you know we're still
looking to see how the wide receiving
corps is gonna come to the floor
obviously Kelvin Benjamin has just been
added and we're you know we need to see
a little bit more consistency from that
unit but in terms of a play making
quarterback and a top-notch top five
potentially player in the NFL at running
back in LeSean McCoy I'm wondering if
you see any similarities between this
team and the seeds that were planted
with the keg on and Marv back in your
day Jim you know what I see I see a team
getting better you know Tyrell a good
example there was a lot of question
marks I'm sure he was little worried too
because you know what it's a new system
he'd come in you know he's been through
a number of them already and a lot of
people out there include myself but how
is everybody gonna handle it the new
offense again and he's come along and
he's making the reads that he needs to
make he's making I think he's probably
one of the best at making plays when
he's on the run I think now he's more so
looking for the open receiver and not
looking to run the ball and we need him
to do that we need him to continue to do
that we need for him to stay healthy
because boy some of the decisions he's
made I'm like wow I can't believe it he
that's a heck of a pass or he makes some
big crucial runs when we need him so
he's playing excellent football and you
hit it right on about LeSean McCoy and
they're finding ways to get him to
football not just in a running game and
open those holes up but find ways to get
him to football in an open field and
have him have people miss one or two
times and come up with that big play so
we just need to stay healthy rich the
defense need to continue to
get the turnovers and we need to stay on
that plus side on that turnover ratio
and I like so far what we see but I know
it's only you know little under a half
the season but tell you what I like what
we got Jim Kelly joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show Friday at 9:00 eastern
time I can't believe that we haven't
done in a football life on you yet Jim
I'm assuming because I know an official
well I know but look man I can't wait to
see this and I know NFL Network and NFL
Films usually shows it to these subjects
before they aired a it airs have you
seen it yet Jim yes I have I'm very
impressed
if I had to say one minor thing well to
me it's major but for most people's
party minor I wouldn't love to have had
my high school football coach in it a
little bit more because he was a guy
that meant so much to my life and it's
called a football life and my head coach
Terry Henry from high school was that
guy that kept me on the straight and
narrow made sure I did what I had to do
and made sure that my mindset leaving
East Brady was intact it you know you're
going to a place where yeah your numbers
are tired you're the best here but so
was everybody else there it's going to
be your work ethic that's going to
separate you it's your passion you have
for the game it's going to separate you
from the other so and as a matter of
fact richer you know this I think this
year is the only year I think in the
last 29 30 years at my high school
football coach there's not going to be
at the Super Bowl with because it's in
Minnesota so they all decided to boycott
this year's Super Bowl so I'm going just
with one of my brothers and but my high
school coach Terry Henry has been a big
pivotal part of my life and really I
probably wouldn't be an appropiate if it
wasn't for him so that's the only little
part but other than that I thought they
did an excellent excellent job of really
talking about my life but as the
producer told me the other day said Jim
we could have done three or four
football I says how much you have going
on in your life but you know I'm least
I'm here to be able to talk about it
well in that regard
- he's not miked up but again we have
one of our longtime listeners on in our
set here from Delaware stage for cancer
Pete has I'm wondering he's not miked up
but give them an attaboy Jim you you
know what it's like to be dealing with
with this disease go for it if you don't
mind I'll give you the floor here yeah
no problem all you know what the thing
is I've learned through my tough times
and I've been through a lot I mean
you'll see on the football life which
airs tomorrow night that we all go
through tough times in our life but it's
your attitude that you have to persevere
through it and inspire others and the
thing is we can always as you know
cancer survivors even when we're going
through it so sorry to a certain point
why this I mean I went through four
Super Bowls I had a son born on my
birthday who you know wind up dying of a
fatal genetic disease and we can easily
give up and feel sorry and you know
sometimes at times point fingers but the
thing is we can understand we're men
we're gonna stand up with you to
continue to fight in and you get to
surround yourself with good quality
people but in the side inside your heart
and get understand that hey there's ways
of getting through this helping other
people also even when I was fighting I
was trying to make sure that other
people Romney they were going through
tough times that I was able to help them
out by talking by that word so all I can
say is keep fighting never ever give up
as Jimmy V always said but the thing is
as I look at my life and I looked at
your life and you know stage four cancer
you never know keep the prayers coming
because I know I live by the fluorescent
number was my faith I know the good Lord
has different plans for me and is he's
not done with me yet so never ever give
up keep fighting along you got loved
ones around you and just you know hey
I'm gonna beat it that's the attitude
that you gotta have I don't care if it
stays three four whatever it is they
give me weeks I'm fighting to the end so
I wish you the best god bless you and
I'll be praying for you you the man Jim
a lot of claps and head nods and not a
dry eye in the house love you Jim Kelly
love you love you with all my heart you
take care of yourself we'll chat soon I
appreciate rich I love you too man
you've always been one of my favorites
and always will but you take care god
bless and I will see you soon buddy
I gotcha that's Jim Kelly Pro Football
Hall of Famer for more Rich Eisen show
tuned to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Rich Eisen show app